it is a new era off the strip as virgin
hotels las vegas opens its doors for the
first time tonight thank you for joining
us at six
i'm brian loftus and i'm denise valdez
after a series of delays from the
pandemic
the day has finally arrived the former
hard rock hotel location kicking things
off in style tonight with a massive
grand opening celebration
and we are tracking it all with team
coverage arko mana is live from the
property with more on what you can
expect on your first visit
but first let's go to sasha loftis
several celebrities on hand and of
course
a las vegas style grand opening
celebration we haven't seen in a long
time sasha
yes denise you are right it has been
quite the celebration here for the grand
opening
of virgin hotels las vegas that many
have really been waiting for now we saw
dozens of people lining up outside
before they were allowed to come in for
the first time and just
see everything inside so much excitement
you can see the red carpet here laid
down as those vip guests arrive for the
special occasion
the socially distant celebration
includes some big names like mario lopez
matt james tom sandoval tom schwartz and
melissa gorga
we also had a drum line here that was
pretty exciting and some pretty creative
photo opportunities with that double
decker bus
we were able to speak with a few of the
executives at the beginning of the
ceremony
they really spoke about how the opening
of this hotel is really ceremonial
after a year of closures here in las
vegas
the doors are now unlocked may we live
in a world that
may las vegas live in a world where we
never have to close
doors again to our resorts
now the ceremony itself is wrapped up
but the party is just starting that
opening celebration
that's set to continue through the
evening with everyone here socially
distanced with mass
outside on the red carpet and inside the
hotel
now we will of course be here all night
speaking with everyone and just
getting a feel of all that excitement
that electric energy we'll check in in a
little while here
in this newscast but first we'll go
ahead and send it over to orco mana who
is also
outside the property tonight in orco you
have more on what everyone can expect
inside the hotel it's just really
exciting all around
[Music]
that's right sasha very exciting we can
feel the excitement in the air
even where we are here in the parking
lot and now that guests are actually
able to go inside
virgin hotels las vegas they're in for a
real treat
now after a 200 million dollar
renovation
this is what you can expect to see
there's a desert oasis theme
with natural colors gems and plants
filling the lobby
and really the whole property there are
fifteen hundred rooms across
three towers sixty thousand square feet
of casino space as well as new
restaurants
the hotel also has contactless features
like an app to control the tvs
lights and to order room service even
more good news is providing
so many job opportunities we have 1300
returning employees from hard rock
that's about 85 percent of the employees
that stayed to the end
when it was a hard rock we've hired an
additional 400
we're also told that virgin hotels las
vegas plans to hire an additional four
to 500 employees
throughout may which is when the resort
pool and day club are set to open and
what's also really exciting
is that there are no resort fees at this
property we're told
that the goal is to make everything
affordable for locals
and tourists alike reporting live from
virgin hotels las vegas tonight orca
mana 8 news now